we start riding and boarding and just at
some point we start developing the
character and it's usually when the
characters flaw comes into focus for
example you know we knew we had an old
man up who's gonna be cranky and Toy
Story we knew we had a cowboy that was
going to be jealous and these flaws
start coming forward and mean emo Albert
Brooks you know was afraid of his son
going off into the to the ocean and it
suggests who the person could be but the
thing that we do is we find someone that
can balance that flaw and so woody
played by Tom Hanks I mean he's jealous
of buzz but he is Tom Hanks about as
appealing as you can get and Ed Asner
you know we you know as soon as we
started getting a sense that this guy
was going to be a curmudgeon you know a
tester came to mind because he plays
curmudgeon about as funny as anyone can
play curmudgeon and he balances his flaw
and so it seems like once we we get
their weakness we can find someone who
can balance that weakness we start out
just grabbing people in the halls -
literally - you know we we know we have
to make our story reels we don't have a
professional actor and so we have a team
of about I don't know 20 25 people that
do voices within Pixar just animators
and people that work in the cafeteria
that just happened to be pretty good at
acting in and so there's you know
serving up the the beans one minute and
then they're doing a scratch voice for
for Carl Fredricksen the next and but
the nice thing is it you know it gives
us a bit of time to develop the
character before we commit and you know
we workshop that character from
beginning to end and the scratch voices
in particular are very important to find
the cadence of the character and the
tone of the character and you struggle
for about the first six months you
really don't know that character and
you're scratch actors can can propel you
forward and at that point you know you
as well as finding the flaw in the
character they can point to a specific
actor that you can hire and I got to say
no scratch actor very few can can really
come forward with such depth and
wonderful acting as the people we bring
in Ellen DeGeneres John Goodman and
Billy Crystal you know they really know
how to bring a character to life and one
thing they know how to do really well is
not overact I think as scratch actors we
tend to overact a bit and you'll you'll
be in a voice session with with someone
like Billy Crystal and he'll give this
small performance and you think well it
won't that won't work but it ends up
working because these guys really know
their craft well sometimes they don't
the animators don't even show you what
the character looks like so what he or
she does is say she's old she's sweet
she's nice or she's ill-tempered or
whatever it is and so that's how you do
it but you have to recall how you felt
at a certain time how you would react
but you use that voice that you're
supposed to use
I taught voiceovers at USC a lot of the
young people would say hey that's for a
listen and they did wonderful voices but
you get copy in front of them and they
couldn't act so I think it has to be
inherent in you to have that ability to
act whether you could do funny voices or
different voices or not you have to have
that emotion that's just born when I did
witch hazels you have to hunched over a
little bit because he go hey you know
and and you you feel like a fool
sometimes if you were in a party you
know all these crazy voices but once I
was in the telephone booth you know they
used to have them on the streets yes
anyway Pat Buttram used to call me when
he he fits the gene after scope and then
he he has a radio show and he would call
me every Halloween as witch-hazel to
find out what the witches were wearing
well that day I wasn't home I had a
studio call so I went into one of these
telephone booths and I called him and I
said the little vixen and there were
people waiting to get in and they kept
looking at each other what kind of a nut
is that and the telephone